ryan reynolds the deadpool star is now
swimming in the money pool after cashing
in on his
gin
he's on the night ryan sold his aviation
american gin line for 610 million
dollars
to the same company that bought george
clooney's tequila but
it's not exactly the gravy train ryan
thought he's actually getting a little
more than
half that well up front he's gonna get
335 million and then the rest depends on
what happens with sales over the course
of the next 10 years
so there's a little risk associated with
this as well and bringing his star power
to it is really going to show us if his
name
translates into sales after reading the
fine
print on the deal ryan wrote a hilarious
out of office email reply
saying quote i'd like to take this
opportunity to apologize
to everyone i told to go blank
themselves in the last 24 hours
my lawyers just explained i'm not as
george clooney as i thought
to those listed below i'm sorry he named
wife
blake his mom clooney the rock betty
white and others
ryan now wants them to help him market
his liquor
what you got a little buddy little smith
works vodka now i got a vodka too so
yeah stripping vodka yeah exactly
i've been taste testing this tequila for
months and months and months
i've become a connoisseur and a drunk
all at the same time many famous faces
have mixed it up in the booze biz
the rock and his joe bro jumanji co-star
both have tequilas we are here at the
house that skinny girl bill
former real housewife bethany frankel
got an estimated 100 million dollars
to sell off her skinny girl cocktails
line but it's dad to twins clooney who's
the billion dollar tequila tycoon
my wife said i can't name them casa and
amigos
that's the one thing i'm not allowed to
do well clooney sold his uh brand of
tequila casamigos back in 2017 to diago
it was a 700 million dollar deal
and about 300 was based on performance
over time
sales have been doing real well
you